one of the reasons why there at least
two reasons what I want to show you this
question number one it's quite
challenging so the good chance a lot of
you ask me this question anyway
particularly it's a lot of a classic
type of question many questions you can
quickly see as we've done this you can
easily design a question that's very
much like this but the all of the
equations that end up different but the
same kind of basic strategy will still
work so here's the premise 72
centimeters string of wire okay and
they're going to cut it into two pieces
to form a circle and a square like this
this is an optimization problem what
they want is the smallest area overall
the smallest total area okay now the
reason why this is a question is because
for example this is one of the answers
it's not the only one right for instance
maybe this is produced by slicing right
across the middle okay and then here's a
circle here's a square but of course I
don't have to cut there there's nothing
that tells me I have to I could for
instance cut up here and have a really
little circle and a much bigger square
right so at some point I'm going to get
the minimum area and that's what the
question is
okay by the way I could just as equally
have asked what's the maximum area but
that uh I'll let you have a think about
why that's a different kind of question
will address that another time so how do
I approach this question what is the
first thing I would do okay yeah I need
to know if what I'm trying to optimize
for is the sum of these two areas well I
need to know the two areas okay now
interestingly I'm actually going to come
to that a fair way into the question I
need to find some stuff I've got no
variables or anything that allows me to
even access the question okay so I have
to choose a variable I can assign it
they don't tell me I don't think they
tell you they don't write
they don't say let X equal this or y
equal that it's completely up to us okay
now I would say there are two logical
choices both of which are fine
there could both answer this question
okay when you're working at the area of
a circle
what leg do you use you just use the
radius so I couldn't define this leg as
Pratibha which is a pretty ball and then
get every other value in this question
from that provable alternatively what's
the links that you used to find the area
square if it's a square all I need is
the side length okay excuse me so I
could then define that to be some letter
s for side length or something like that
and then I can work out everything else
in this question in terms of that
variable
now just because it was the first one
that I tried I went with the top one I
said let's define let's call this guy R
and work out everything else but I'll
leave it as an exercise to you to try
going in the other direction to find
this and you will get the same Advocates
the same problem it's just all phrased
in different programs okay so if the
radius is R so this is let's actually
set this question up let the radius or
let the circle radius not that anything
else has a radius of this B are
centimeters okay so what can I get from
there I can work out the area of the
circle right what's the area of the
circle so I'm going to have to come back
to that that's important okay I'm going
to need to know some information about
this thing I need to do it area and then
I can add them up together but in order
to work out this area I need to know its
side length right so how do I get to
that now I could introduce another
pruning rule but it's a bad idea because
then I'm going to have equations with
multiple variables in them and it's
going to be hard to solve I can get it
in terms of our right this square is
made up of the leftovers from this
circle do you agree how much wire did I
use to make the circle
it's the circumference that's how much
wire was required to make this so
therefore the circumference is 2 pi R
and the leftovers are used for the
square
so therefore the perimeter of the square
is going to be equal to what are the
leftovers 72 take away all this stuff
you ok with that
so the question does say this is how
much wire you get ok all right now
perimeter is good but I didn't want
prudhoe I wanted area so how do I get
from area to for a front perimeter how
do I do it I'll divide by 4 to get side
lengths so side of this is equal to that
divided by 4 I can simplify ever so
little by saying this how's that look so
look ok and now the reason why I have
the side like this so I can work out the
area this times this what do you think
how does it look happy ok yes that's all
right fine ok
so now I've gotten from a definition of
a link through everything I need to know
about this question in terms of that
length okay so now I've got both areas I
want to get a in terms of are the total
area right so the total area will be one
plus the other this Plus this whoops
that's 36 okay so that's just the sum of
the areas isn't it now it looks a bit
messy just remember where you're going
what's the goal what's the goal I want
the smallest area think about what
technique because you've got three of
them what technique is probably going to
be most useful for you in terms of this
guy does it look like it's going to be
nice to factorize I don't know about you
but I'm not very familiar with the
factors of Pi so I might leave that one
to one side okay what were our other two
techniques you could complete the square
or you could use the formula for the
axis of symmetry okay I don't really
want to complete the square with this
anymore then I want to factorize it so I
think I'd sort of mapping forward my
head I think where I'm going to go is -
Bo - eh okay but in order to work out
one - Bo - eh I need to know B and a so
what shall I do
I couldn't tradition substitution here
however there's not really any
compelling reason to do so because it's
already a quadratic admittedly it's a
quadratic with messy numbers but it's
not like it was a quartic or something
with side squared it or something like
that
it's already a quadratic just a messy
one okay so here's what I'm going to do
I see that PI R squared right
that pi we part of a do you agree part
of the coefficient of the squared term
but part of it also tucked in here so
I'm going to need to expand do you see
while doing that I need to collect some
like terms so let's do this do you agree
that this first term is four PI R
squared on for that okay why would I
write that oh don't do that
because this guy is on four so I'll
write this now what do I do
I think I'm going to need to expand this
guy what's like goodbye that so I'll
check the quarter out the front I want
to go to four PI R squared plus 36 times
36
1296 because we all know are 36 so
tables pretty well there's the a squared
here comes the minus 2 a B it will be
minus 72 pi R what do you think yeah
and then plus B squared which in this
case will be pi squared R squared has
that look that work okay just my
arithmetic check out okay
now the purpose of us doing this was to
be able to get a B and a out of it right
do you see the a is tucked in here and
yeah yeah where's the beef which tends
to be yeah and there is that plus 1296
irrelevant why what effect is the plus
1,000 children on if you have on a
parabola what to do and just moves it up
and down it doesn't change the axis of
symmetry
what about this one quarter what effect
does that have yeah it scales it up and
down but also doesn't move the axis of
symmetry anywhere so that's why these
guys are the important numbers okay so
I'm going to write it just in one more
step to make it really really clean and
obvious let's try to add a at the front
for PI plus PI squared that's how many I
Squared's I have do you agree
r squared minus 72 pi art there's the B
and I don't really care about this guy
but he's there so I'd better write him
you happy